this is hurricane durian on September
1st 2019 and here it is more than 24
hours later still pummeling those same
islands you see hurricane durian it's
stalled right there in its path in fact
at times it was crawling across the
Bahamas at just one point six kilometers
per hour that's slower than the average
person walks so what causes hurricanes
like durian to stall and why does it
matter
[Music]
first of all durian is not the first
hurricane to stall not even close
actually in 2018 for example hurricane
Florence spent more than 50 hours within
one small region of North Carolina and
the year before harvey lingered over the
houston area for more than two days
straight but in every case hurricanes
that stall are really bad news because
the longer they linger the more rain
they unload and the more damage they
deal Harvey for example dropped more
than sixty inches of rain in some parts
of Texas and it cost the country an
estimated 125 billion dollars
doreen on the other hand dropped more
than 36 inches of rain in some regions
and is expected to have a multi-billion
dollar price tag as well so then why -
hurricane stall in the first place
think of a hurricane like a cork bobbing
in a stream although it produces its own
wind and spin it actually travels thanks
to larger wind patterns which carry it
along those wind patterns themselves
evolve and change and sometimes the
winds that guide to hurricanes collapse
endures what you might think of as a
stagnation point
that's Tim Hall I'm a senior scientist
at NASA's Goddard Institute for Space
Studies in New York and he says that at
these stagnation points a hurricane has
nowhere to go so it just sits there
dropping rain until another wind system
picks it up and pushes it along and
that's exactly what happened in the
Bahamas when Dorian arrived a pressure
system nearby called the North Atlantic
subtropical ridge started to weaken and
that caused winds that were carrying the
hurricane to essentially stopped blowing
and it will definitely happen again in
fact those stagnation events they're
actually becoming more common and as a
result so are hurricanes that stall
according to Hall's research there were
66 hurricanes that stalled in the North
Atlantic between 1944 and 2017 and
nearly half occurred in the last third
of that time frame which helps explain
another trend the average speed of
hurricanes in a given year is declining
in fact compared to the mid 20th century
hurricanes today are moving on average
about 17% slower
scientists still aren't sure why but
we've got some suspects and the suspects
are that in a warming climate climate
model simulations show both in the
future and in the past several decades a
reduction in the overall tropical wind
patterns and unfortunately a stalled
hurricane isn't the only consequence of
climate change it's also been shown to
worsen storm surge increased rainfall
and produce more intense storms
so while durian is of course devastating
it's likely just one of many hurricanes
like it still to come
[Music]
you